hello and welcome to see you playing the
hair turn with white hoops no
see-through please so without em use for
the night off yeah age 3 I absolutely
like what I'm getting with those lines I
think defined is what he played earlier
[Music]
quite sure but so yeah here the main
question is if white and some water if
white wants the castle short or long
notice I'm definitely playable I think
I'm going for long castle sim let's go
long and then f form maybe f4 earlier
also comes into consideration but i
think it's ok here i can also think
about taking with the rook like rook
takes if I've worked it too so possible
possible gain of tempo I don't know if
this is relevant yeah okay I play the
normal looking if five is actually
interesting here maybe maybe five I
don't need to play a crazy attack every
game at the Sicilian this ending would
be pretty nice I feel Bishop c6 it's not
playing Bishop 26 but look t44 look-see
for looks annoying let's see
and not a very convenient looking
position so i can take or bishop oil
Roxy for Roxy for he's got 95 but I can
just take g7 so this should be bad
[Music]
so what now I can take take f6 here and
then c6 immediately taking doesn't make
any sense but it's not bad i think
question is if i want to take here
immediately probably a yeah want Chani i
can go here and prevent any Bishop f4 I
was kind of irritated by possibility of
Bishop f4 and then Rudy to which of
course he cannot do that I'm just
covering the square so we wants to trade
off this active rook yeah why not it's
not a big deal
[Music]
check aiming for will give you form
again okay now here I have to move it
just wonder where exactly I can go look
the eight next hmm that's not so right
ok so let's go here so that I have not
set 53 if it goes through the aid
who you don't want to take this really
[Music]
and it's not so easy because this Bishop
is quite strong
check
[Music]
okay okay this is very nicely controlled
I need to get my pawns moving I just
wonder how exactly beef before like this
King up and then go from there I don't
like the split points you have to be
bothered Anita you need to remove those
pawns on you probably have to didn't
think about this that the king is so
quick here
now that I should have avoided really
should avoid it down didn't see this
chatting to evaluate this correctly the
King got very active all the Sun my
pawns are sidewalk advance to though
that is good and it doesn't easily get
get here which gives me that have fun
time morning
threatening a fork
check not sure this is enough to win so
let's see how can I do this Nyjah do for
King do six
cuz they cannot go there immediately
check the draw is really unacceptable
but ok what can I do game drawn bad bad
bad bad bad bad play after this position
now somebody's King got to active that
was not good it wasn't it wasn't that
easy anyway because his Bishop is really
strong two really strong Chinese until
yet Bishop d2 anyway so I'm I have to
improve him you have to improve him look
the Warner with tempo this is bad anyway
I'm because I didn't see that Bishop d2
comes when I have to do this he gets far
I mean far less activity check and he a
bishop did too but I didn't I just
overlook this now it looks ok but it's
not that easy it really isn't f4 wow
that was not really on my agenda
[Music]
I try to just keep keep things as they
were yeah g5 i actually did consider but
i wasn't sure about this okay here and
then Knight to f3 okay I didn't really
see 92f three I did consider g5 but did
not evaluate correctly they are sadly
I'm just having a good control of
everything but the King I have to have
to prevent the black king from getting
so active but I don't really know how
somewhere here problem rook g1 and then
Ruby one it make some sensor here things
get extremely tricky check gaff yeah I
should win somewhere and I do it with a
6 ok chance was also meant to be saved
let's say because he I don't risk
anything 93 wins yeah to be five and
promote that also wins though c3 is
pretty bad don't even know what I was
thinking was c3 can also go here this is
just a complete win and I don't know
sometimes it's a little bit strange
here it's a draw is always getting
challenging the pole and here you cannot
win ciao pretty disappointing after the
very nice position i had them ok thanks
for watching